[Music]
now Madeline de l'homme more positio
piranhas on an axis courtesy of July is
a different darling virus can deserve it
deserve nothing
the light is offensive by the forces of
Syrian dictator Bashar Assad on Italy
the last rebel-held province in Syria
went on for three months
entire cities were laid to waste and
hundreds of thousands of people fled
north for the Turkish border since March
there has been a shaky ceasefire and
life has been returning to the streets
but now there is a new deadly threat the
coronavirus what is it like to live in
the war-torn city of eat lab now at a
time when the world is talking about one
threat only the coronavirus we have been
in touch with three residents of it the
province the students asset or dr. Samir
Cadore and mohamed el sheikh who lives
in a refugee camp over the last weeks
they've been sharing their impressions
their concerns and pictures with us
we met such a tour in late february back
then fighting still raged in it lip city
the provincial capital before the
student arrived here she spent almost
two years in various prisons run by the
Assad regime for taking part in the
student demonstration
she says she was tortured and isolated
to jail Sakuni vahana
gonna be more Farida honest all badness
of me an America that would help
Ayesha visa denial of our often
incidental observe both ha ha ha
jerk-off director actually academic
Heritage Trail ikeda eriko service
magazine when is a bizarre happening and
if Adele made a skinny who with a happy
sometimes ahah works as a reporter for
the Syrian opposition broadcaster say
plus meanwhile she's studying Business
Administration and has just been
accepted into an online program at the
American University of Beirut when the
ceasefire was announced at the beginning
of March Saha
remained skeptical in Medina and that's
possible if it was theta Hoffman is all
about Danny's Amadou a man
we drove as a caucus wearing a brutal
civil war has raged in Syria for the
last nine years yet it was to foreign
powers that broke at the ceasefire on
one side there's Russia the Assad
regime's most important ally on the
other there's Turkey which supports the
rebels mainly made up of Islamist groups
the streets of eated city have come
alive since the ceasefire took effect
the markets are well-stocked again and
people are out in droves but just as the
city's residents savor the taste of
freedom the threat of the coronavirus is
looming the first cases of covered 19
have been confirmed in the capital
damascus sahara is worried this man put
on our boots would you excuse me miss
amanda - and that's where Matthew Okoye
Abaddon afternoon module right here
business our company - and he didn't
build her not a flash area but there are
almost a million refugees in the region
with no home left to go to they are
languishing in makeshift camps often in
appalling conditions the 25 year old
Muhammad and his family fled to one of
the camps after their house was
destroyed in an air strike he and a
group of like-minded volunteers built a
small school year he proudly sent us
photos in early March but the sense of
achievement was short-lived
poppin my talk about the one which I'm
an adult I can share that Messiah who
keep that sassy Indian chicken there is
enough water in war mats Kempe but not
in most others
[Music]
essential health measures such as
keeping a safe distance or washing hands
are impossible in many of the camp's
sent Muhammad as he sent us a photo of
him wearing a mask having been through
the traumas of displacement death and
destruction some people just don't see
the threat health workers are trying to
raise the alarm in whatever way they can
face-to-face or via social media we're
going to from chocolatier dearly nanika
Janet of the retina team dr. cat was an
anesthesiologist and general manager at
one of the few hospitals still operating
in Italy province he's trying to prepare
the clinic as best he can even though it
only has to intensive care beds and a
single ventilator and there are only 95
ventilators for a whole region was a
population of more than 3 million dr.
cadra says he's sure it will get worse
than in Italy danger danger then and no
deal mercenary dr. cadra says the
international community is too
preoccupied with itself for Syria to
expect any help soon he and his team are
trying to do what they can they have put
of all non-vital surgeries other
hospitals are disinfecting their lobbies
regularly and taking the temperatures of
new arrivals
most important of all now would be to
test as many people as possible for
covered 19 but it was not until the end
of March that the World Health
Organization sent the first test kids to
e blip now they've got 6,200 kids for
over three million people and even worse
there's only one lab capable of
analyzing the results the students aha
doesn't know if the virus has long since
arrived all the same she has stopped
wearing a mask when she leaves the house
she says she can't stand being stared at
and laughed at anymore
now she exercises a different kind of
caution I did a whole query and I'm in
here - a my bad okay got it
I'm Ken and I can food flash of Lisa
we're the best hello Qatar M cannibalism
bills 8 es la Marck claim back in India
English Way school sent universities
have been closed but there are no
official restrictions on movement yet
nor has there been any sign of panic
buying
all that could change have covered 19
becomes part of daily life year two we
plan to stay in touch with Sahar dr.
kadar and Mohammed and update our eat
lip Diaries with their stories
[Music]